vous avez vu que samedi à sony la fin
d'un long suspense puisque le joueur qui
viennent mba pays que j'adore kilian
j'embrasse tort il ya un amour enfin
choisi entre le psg et le real madrid il
a choisi le paris saint-germain il reste
au paris saint germain alors forcément
alors ça plaît pas tout il ya eu un
moment que ça a fait couler énormément
d'encre entre négociations secrètes
montants astronomiques et déclarations
chocs
que s'est il passé
sachez que c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup
de tweets même à l'étranger c'était
jeanne
la liga contre la liga apparaît plainte
contre le psg ça pour ces transactions
passent monde du fair play financier
mais non ça n'ira pas au bout mais ils
sont mauvais joueur
monumental ce que j'aime bien le real
madrid sékou bâ il espérait amasser
parce que moi j'ai mon fichier je
voulais je devais le mettre là bas
oui deviez mais toi tu seras ils ont
proposé d'ouvrir un stand de merguez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est cuit ça sent aussi pour le magasin
commence à me titiller
tranché on va rester nouveau sur paris
saint germain c'est comme ça
image sportive du week-end c'était ça
allez c'est reparti attention cette
phase ici buzz l'éclair qui s'est
retrouvé le cul par terre et en bois
vrai c'était plutôt ça le trésor s'est
créé ici ici c'est paris et oui le mec
de 23 ans le plus convoité au monde
vient de prendre sa décision alors qu'on
commençait tout ça sympa chanter dans un
feuilleton de plusieurs mois autour du
sort de m bape et la fin d'un
psychodrame qui dure depuis des mois et
des mois tout le monde attendait depuis
des mois et donc samedi que même map est
annoncée au parc des princes qu'il
resterait jusqu'en 2025 de quoi faire
plaisir à des supporters pour qui un
simple bon soir arrive à les mettre en
transe bonjour a tous
pensé moi les supporters du real qui
était persuadé de voir la pépite
débarqué à madrid et est un tout petit
peu des grands combats raison à ma
balle et le réglage crabe à celle ci il
faut dire que certains ont pris la
nouvelle avec beaucoup de philosophie
c'est vrai que c'est plutôt triste comme
nouvelle mais bon vous savez tous que
cyril hamelin jeunes sont p 500 au
paddle moi c'est tout ce qu'ils en
parlent
on
[Applaudissements]
démarre toujours ce sera vraiment
sarcastique j'aime pas ça j'aime pas ça
merci gilles favard d'être là alors
gilles qui a été le premier consultant
sportif à dire que kilian m appelait ça
serait rigolo non alors à celle j
en deux temps deux trios là où beaucoup
géraldine aux valeurs on va c'est vous
les avez dit c'est vous qui la fin de
l'année mais c'est lui qui l'a dit en
reprenant six mois en progressant
ex-aequo mais j'ai dit à 8 mois alors
battu coimères à dire des conneries je
te dis que c'est lui qui l'a dit en
premier d'accord ça t'a dit quoi quoi
devrais j'ai rien dit parce que voilà
quand je sais rien je continue à parler
donc c'est pas le problème mais en fait
si vous le savez il savait et moi je
vous dire je voulais toujours dit qu'il
restait que c'est vrai oui parce que
rien non je savais pas mais ces logiques
très bien
moi je vais partir d'un constat simple
pourquoi
qu'il ya même pas pu regarder le real de
madrid à glénac il actuellement il en
ligue des champions en finale sans qu'il
y ait même baby moi je moi je suis un
joueur je me dis j'ai envie d'amener le
paris saint germain en finale ou gagner
les élections pour une fois la finale
des chances et voilà le real madrid
n'aura gagné plein des ligues des
champions mais sans moi qu'est ce que je
vais faire de plus la laci joue est une
légende voilà c'est comme regarder c'est
comme ces huit réussir sur ces vite oui
c'est beaucoup plus difficile que
réussir sur tf1 c'est pour ça que je
ferme ma gueule et je reste ici
mais voilà si on a écrit mme les gens
regardez regardez vous
ce
qui s'est passé là raconte nous tous la
sq après dyson s'est fait répondre et
gilles verdez
effectivement je n'avais pas d'infos
mais c'était juste une analyse de la
situation at elle pas d'enfants
pas une question d'info mais quand on
connaît un petit peu équivalent canin
pas d'infos
n'est pas venu pour ça
les invités ce soir plutôt calme si ma
fille veut qu'on recommence on va
recommencer gilles verdez c'est pas un
problème qu'est ce qu'il a bâti lui dis
ce que tu as lui dire j'ai rien à lui
dire c'est une oeuvre d'art
abbas est une oeuvre d'art si vous le
mettez en bas de la tour eiffel tous les
pieds tous les chiens vont lui pisser
dessus
[Applaudissements]
et
du gros temps les boues
je veux
à personne
[Applaudissements]
je veux tu vois ça tu as la vie j'ai
battu haas
alors qu'est ce qu'il a écrit mme
ottaway questionné il l'a dit il l'a dit
lui donne ni n'importe quoi manu payet
c'est vrai nom je peux lui poser une
question qui sort un peu du dominion
gênant c'est un cosy lattois pas très
bon je fais un coût humain donc à la
vanille voient pas très précis c'est sur
le dossier mbappé oui c'est pas ça le
bcm bas alors banon je sais pas
recommencer encore alors dit non il est
vraiment pénible
non mais c'est que c'est qu'on saisit
pas donne des infos c'est quoi tes
anticipe pas d info j'ai bien dit je
viens de rafic et mais dis moi il ce qui
vient faire ici alors qu'aralar
[Applaudissements]
c'est les deux mecs du muppet show et
ses aléas
j'aimerais américaine ares sa rise of
massachusetts le massachusetts hier est
aussi bien comme il faut je viens de
tomber sur la route de memphis
quand on connais un petit peu ce milieu
la façon dont ça se découpe pas bien sûr
quand qu'en septembre et octobre sont
passés et qu'il n'y avait rien qui
s'annonçait on savait que l'émirat
allait rentrer dans le nord dans
l'ariège l'émir images oui les menhirs
et son cas allait rentrer dans l'action
et du jour où il est rentré dans
l'action ba tout c'est un petit peu tout
c'est un petit peu chamboulé du que
leonardo était hors jeu depuis le début
aitor genou est en jeu ne pouvait pas
discuter avec sa famille s'en voulait
pas donc là ils l'ont dit les parties
coupez les en a redoublé par saint louis
et où
il y retournait milan chez moi j'ai vu
la semaine dernière bah oui mais c'est
ma dernière ses faubourgs de là j'ai vu
j'ai vu je dis non oui c'est lundi la
médaille
est magnifique tout ça te dirait de
choper jettent ou non la mine on voulait
qu'ils jouent au père noël
ouais mais c'est un boulot
[Applaudissements]
j'ai vu ça j'ai vu un poteau de corner
maintenant tu vois non juste
gilles est ce qu'on peut avoir les
montants parce que c'est vrai que
derrière on voudrait savoir ça alors
yacine et pourquoi pas ce qu on entend
plein de choses on entend on a entendu
300 millions de prime à la signature
mary 100 millions par an est maintenant
en fait on parle de 50 millions par an
sur trois ans gilles et sous 100
millions à l'alsace et le salaire vous
allez donner le salaire salaire 50
millions par an ouais sa phrase 150
millions net sur les trois ans et le
real madrid proposé sur cinq ans enfin
même chose ça aurait été la masse et sa
part qu'on a annoncé une prime à la
signature de 300 millions parce qu'il ya
pas de frais de transfert c'est faux
s'est fait rassurant la spa sont comtois
exactement 100 ans 130 millions voilà
c'est ça va pas 300 millions de ça c'est
essentiel plus de 60 millions par an
voilà et le real propose est
sensiblement la même chose c'est pas une
affaire d'argent wallace a dit de rester
en france en dix ans aujourd'hui c'est
la france c'est mon pays et quand gilles
dit l'émir est entré dans la danse c'est
totalement faux c'est emmanuel macron
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire lilas il a dit
certains mais attends attends mais
il laisse parler les adultes parce qu'à
ce temps là les enfants évolution
est
ce que tu vas dire que des conneries
qu'il parlait de l'argent tu nies que
des bêtises alors il a sur trois ans ou
mal est l'argent c'est ça c'est certain
ben oui tu as la même baisse depuis 12
ans
samedi j'ai le phare vous allez à la
finale de ligue des champions real
madrid liverpool vous y aller ou pas oui
pourquoi pas des billets à vendre parce
que en 98
je peux tu expliquer je peux tu
expliquer je m'en fous j'ai été condamné
à 10 mois avec sursis et 5000 euros
d'amendé tellement j'avais fait des
trucs débiles c'est bon mais quand tu
travailles dans des sociétés qu'un titre
chose que tu as jamais eu surtout que
toi tu as passé ta vie est journaliste
et à faire des fausses notes de frais
donc ta ta ta ta ta vraiment raison
d'attaquer
le parisien l'équipe le parisien et à
chaque fois on t'as demandé des comptes
noël pas raison d'attaquer les autres là
dessus je suis
là messieurs
non
si quentin souvent
facile tu aurais pas mais par comprend
du tout moi sa chute aurait permis aux
prud'hommes contre le parisien jamais
cette affaire n'a gagné aux prud'hommes
tu peux retrouver au chômage et à
demander à des gens de payer après le
chômage qui veut maintenant on peut
parler on peut parler vos dossiers
reconnaît par ailleurs seller de gilles
verdez mais moi je suis gentil qui sont
là l'entraînent pour faire un petit peu
tu es en train de te refaire c'est bien
la question de changer de version
écoute moi évident de dire des bêtises
d'un bêtise dis moi ce que je veux dire
y'a qu'à te que je vais dire il ya un
taux que je comprends pas j'ai 70 ans
moi j'ai jamais été serein sur steam
d'air et tout ça tout et vient de
m'écrire c'est lui connaît
[Applaudissements]
je suis un vieux con marché passe côté
thunder sétois fatou je le voudrais te
rencontrer dès 21h15 après l'émission
c'est fatou je sais pas
toujours w
le jour où je vais me lever c'est mieux
foutu elle me lever tu vas voir ce que
ça va ça c'est un effet du vin des 1000
trois mois d'un coup au total je sois
gentil sur les sectes je t'ai déjà dit
je te le répète en boucle des gangs
personnes mes enfants sont au lit alors
là on va pas embêter
trois ans de contrat il ya 600 millions
nets d'impôts et tu veux ou tu veux si
tu améliores si c'est oui on est droit
dans biens des ce que tu sais pas qui
c'est il y aura une fondation une lettre
mais tu connais rien t'as jamais fade
hausse y est ami donc tu connais pas tu
as fait tu as fait que faire des trucs
en effet gt 220 contre ça fait plaisir
ou encore faire que voilà tout écrivent
non plutôt clamé moi je suis jean tigana
mais moi je fasse même bordel ensemble
je veux pas que
mon souhait c'est bon vous dès
maintenant c'est vrai dans tous les cas
il peut rien apporter général céder un
faux
nez attentes a téléphoné à ton ami là tu
sais qui ça abete betico
dante doha week-end lui
mais je ne sais pas s'il a et on a dit
wallerand placer ses comptes vernet se
retourna par là qui t'appelle je peux
pas le blairer
très bien qui est ton ami et je suis
d'accord avec des vertueux a oui c'est
bon allez on parle de vrai qu'il ya même
map et je te le dis ton ami senna et kim
alain
gilles les bois et moi j ça aurait été
moins leurs prix la tâche mais c'est
très bien fait pas non c'est parce que
dit il il a juste dit je vais te la
mettre moi j'aurais mis donc merci
je vois je mettrais mois donc ferme-la
oui gilles les nazis non je suis alors
sûr qu'il ya trois ans ce sera six
semaines lauaki senio russell a suscité
tout mais je vous promets que l'on
aimerait si tu sais c'est bon bah on va
on passe à autre on peut parler de ça
alors toi tu dis donc 50 millions lui
dit de 100g pas d'avis
[Applaudissements]
donc deux sens je suis donc sûr les
trois ans ce sera aux alentours de 600
millions nets d'impôts mal tout confondu
sympa il ya une chose qui va falloir
être agile cette bonne nouvelle
c'est moi ça me choque pas c'est le
sportif qui souhaitent fortifs le mieux
payé en france ou ailleurs tiens ça me
choque pas parce qu'on parle pas trop
d'argent moi je regarde j'adore le
joueur j'adore le
j'adore l'homme il ya une autre chose
qui va falloir mettre en compte ces
quais les jeux olympiques en 2024 ici je
pense que le président de la république
l'a appelé pour certainement lui
demander un petit peu ses attentes et ce
qu'il espérait alors il a dit à l'ats
plus tout le monde c'est vrai vous
l'avez à la pub ah oui bah oui mais le
sais tout je sais ce qu'est comme à
l'école c'était le petit rapporteur
toile
c'est
c'est comment tu n'iras pas une info
samu et d'un fauteuil où tu t'es fait
virer par tous a jamais eu d'infos tu as
fait des émissions tapadas photo raconte
que des conneries donc soit gentil
laisse parler les hommes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
tous les arts dont on aura la réponse de
gilles le
sien delà des amis
tu l'a défendu la dernière fois je sais
très bien qui sait et c'est vrai je vous
promets que je suivrai ne ment pas mon
prix je ne mens pas c'est bon on s'en
fout encore plus du monde en plus tu
monte à bord on va parler qu'ils aiment
ça tu es bon tu es pris en flagrant
délit de mensonge il passe son temps à
l'appeler ça fait mal aux guignols la
raclée club
avec moi tu verras comment tu rentres
dans les stades avec moi pour moi si je
suis un clown d'engins suspects
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît
ton ami est ton ami ton ami mais c'est
qui
je n'ai pas de téléphone
c'est très vague et on ne donnera pas
son nom dont les notes de moi série
d'annoncés qui sait tous les deux films
c'est
parfois c'est pour ça que l'on désirait
d'équipé c'est pas mon ami a laissé
bonjour de la noc le nom il a envie il
en vit il en a des envies de jouer les
jeux olympiques qui est dans sa ville et
dans son pays je vais tout cas le
capitaine des jeux olympiques il avait
fait un peu la tronche parce qu'il
n'avait pas été aux jeux olympiques de
vos derniers jeux olympiques il n'avait
pas pu jouer parce que le club n'avait
pas libéré il ya quelque chose qui est
symbolique sur les jeux olympiques c'est
le dernier relayeur qui allume la vasque
nation si demain vous faites un sondage
quel est le sportif que vous mettez en
premier qu'il y à voile à la caisse à la
voilà ce que c'est que ça a joué bah
c'est symbolique quand même assez ce qui
appuie symbolique donc est ce que ça
sera lui ben le feuilleton commence il
ya deux ans de feuilleton oui mariant du
voile a parlé d'un d'après accord a été
donné à killian papa qui viennent à au
real c'est vrai c'est pas vrai un web et
mobile ou un une parole donnée parce que
ça on en a beaucoup parlé non tout au
long du week end puisque c'est vrai ce
que c'est pas vrai mais qu'est ce que tu
veux qu'il en soit
je vais te répondre sur ce que je l'aï
su parce que bon ça va on peut essayer
de discuter sérieusement il peut pas y
avoir de près de pré accord signé ça
n'existe pas puisqu'il est libre à
partir du 1er janvier s'ils signent à
partir du 1er janvier il est au real il
fait ramer mobile non non non ça c'est
pas grave ça se fait pas cesser il n'y a
pas de choses comme ça il surtout faut
pas que ça traîne ce genre de chose qui
ait des discussions qu'il ait vu perez
une fois dix fois vingt fois la première
classe et pour trois ans leïla il a
signé pour trois ans ici moi je pense
qu'ils aient jamais eu de retour ni là
il a étudié les deux les deux choses il
a pesé le pour et le contre
contrairement à ce que disent les
espagnols qui disent qu'à même beaucoup
de conneries et depuis longtemps et ça
il va pas me contredire ça fait 30 ans
qui raconte que des conneries
constamment les espagnols surtout quand
il parle sur nous le problème va être
simple il a 23 ans dans trois ans il
aura 25 26 connaissent pas il n'est pas
éternel l'oréal bah il signera au real
le rallye zx était morte mais maintenant
d'accord il mars idée
mais je vais me marie avec football
c'est comme
ça de mémoire et je te le dis gilbert
n'y aura pas au real et six mirage plus
jamais au real aime leur chante aussi
mais me dira en 2006 il droit real c'est
dans la boîte qui vont te le ressortir
dans trois ans chez paul tu serais un
club ce sera peut-être à l'ehpad
[Applaudissements]
qui est dirigé par les socios c'est
pardonneront pas il a perdu sept cent
mille abonnés sur un style à la censure
mais non c'est pas vrai il irait loin
trois horizons oublier va y aller je
prends bien tu verras rimer faut que tu
te trompes tu verras tu te trompe mais
il a peut-être raison même avant trois
ans ça se trouve il ya même dans deux
ans et rêve et tg apprendre à blanc
après quelques dons peut-être qu'il a en
2024 sécateur moi je vois comme ça oui
jeremy gilley si vous avez dit que grâce
à la relation qu'il entretenait avec
macron depuis la dernière coupe du monde
macro l'avait appelée il avait peut-être
qu'au feu voilà aidé dans sa décision et
est ce que sarkozy aussi l'appeler ou
pas je sais pas non parce que sarkozy a
aussi amené par également au menu
également que rené coty
rappelé mme papilles
insidieux vercingétorix dans une
relation avec le prince et bien sûr
l'attraction quand même 10 mai tandis
que c'est jean ferrat il paraît que le
pays veut vraiment construire l'équipe
autour demba pays qui veulent peut-être
moins de stars internationales et plus
de joueurs français est ce que c'est
vrai c'est un peu ce qu'on veut tous les
amoureux du football qu'il voit c'est ce
que je veux moi c'est ce qu'on veut
maintenant est-ce qu'ils vont s qui vont
accéder à cette demande il ya que qu'ils
le savent maintenant comment ils
montrent comment ils vont gérer il
paraît que pochettino va sauter quel
entraîneur ils vont avoir à dire on
parle design j'y crois pas du tout moi
personnellement j'y crois pas moi j'y
crois
non du tout du tout d'avoir ça rien à
voir nos soldats ou je pense qu'il a pas
une tranquille will et moi je t'aimais
je t'aime lui tranquille
je te mets une petite pièce
bien
voilà je prends ton billet je me
rappelle
qu'on fait des affaires
oui gilles non j'ai rien à dire à favars
mais il ira y lira jamais au real
d'accord c'est là je suis pas d'accord
là dessus pas d'accord avec toi mais
d'ifadem sympathie dont deux en mai mais
tu sais pas et là je mets et vous
comment vous pouvez savoir la lauréate à
6h colle aux fesses avril sur les
témoignages des mecs qui m'ont dit je
prendrai jama nouna je te le dis non a
battu - bah dis pas de bêtises tu dis
libye cali leur grève et syrie c'est
vrai qu'à style a dit je travaillerai
jamais que moi finalement ben bernard
montiel il a dit je travaillerai jamais
à côté de la médaille
voilà et ben regarde aujourd'hui mais
je vous dis alors il paraît aussi que ça
va être un peu le patron aussi dans le
pré qui fâchent mais aussi au sein du
goût du club où ça c'est dû à d'autres
genres sas et on lui prête beaucoup
d'attention il y va quand même pas tout
faire c'est pas un homme orchestre un
camp sur un essai d'abord un joueur de
foot qui a déjanté qualifiant le
jugement est certainement le meilleur
joueur au monde à l'heure actuelle avec
karim non mais karim ben amor j'espère
qu'il aura le ballon d'or certes sur la
ligue des champions j'espère que le réal
va gagner la ligue des champions pour
qui l'espagne samedi oui j ça oui je
serai faux billets qui malheureusement
cette tombe je serai c'est moi qui lui
passe les miniers
[Musique]
je veux pas dire le prix parce que c'est
en effet une attaque à thumeries
n'empêchait un je vous dirais je
voudrais dire merci à madame on est
encore le président du directoire de
canal mm avoir quatre places 4
elle n'avait même pas la moitié d'une
pour moi
c'est vrai j'étais place maintenant non
parce que j'ai eu avec mon fils
prenez deux places à 2 bahia monfils
place quatre personnes il ya mon fils
de mon fils et avec un ami et son fils
également ça va j'ai regardé à la télé
non c'était
c'était quoi la déconnade
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que j'y vais voilà bon merci
merci est ce que tu as un truc a ajouté
mme jean fabbri donc mais je vais
attendre la sortie peut-être ah oui
j'attends quelqu'un la sortie
qu'est-ce que vous avez tous les deux
savent pas ce que disent que j'ai dirigé
la vérité je n'avais jamais vu j'aimais
jamais adressé la part dans cette
situation mais la guerre est plus dure
sera la réputation parce que sinon au
delà d'un truc je
ne supporte pas ça je te le dis moi je
juge sur pièce moi j le jeu comprend
plus que ce sera très bon chroniqueur
est allé quoi je vous le dis franchement
il ya et je déteste les mecs qui sont
directs a fait sa priorité des a priori
six mois alors tu me juger sur des a
priori tout ce qu'on dit sur moi et bah
tu serais pas là c'est encore bien donc
arrête de juger on voit comme ailier moi
je rejoins là c'est un mec que j'aime
bien voilà c'est tout après on verra
bien on a le talent qu'est ce qui
dérangeait train qu'est ce qui le
dérangeait travailler sur le bonhomme
après la bête en espagne avec cette
époque qui t'ont dis ça mais pas où je
n'étais pas très chaud c'est très bien
qu'ils aient des jeunes sétois et c'est
moi qui vais le parti
n'est pas ce que tu vas finir ça va mal
finir
je te dis je sais très bien qu'ils
tapent année je ne sais pas de qui
minent actuellement comme un arracheur
de communion
c'est possible
et l'on sache si le gars il a vu je t'ai
vu tout à l'heure tu la paix à 17 heures
voilà dans les loges voilà à ouidah
[Applaudissements]